on n'est pas avec des parfums il ce soir
là aujourd'hui on a tout installer des
pelouses adverses un mouvement pacifique
devenu mondial et qui tend à perdurer au
canada déjà deux semaines que des
dizaines de kg à l'honneur glock
plusieurs axes routiers frontaliers la
ville d'ottawa positionné en partie
devant le parlement les convoyeurs de la
liberté entendent encore rester un
certain temps a mentionné pour deux
trois jours qui fait mal dans ma main
j'espère sinon 28 janvier se retourner
chez nous tous tenté un tank us amati
budget dans la zone rouge cj compris à
quel point c'est important d'être fait
de rester ici en zone rouge parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'un certain ils rentrent à
pau se retrouvant dans une impasse face
aux manifestants le gouvernement décide
de changer de stratégie doug ford le
premier ministre de l'ontario a annoncé
vendredi déclaré l'état d'urgence sur
l'ensemble de la région il s'est
également adressé directement aux
convoyeurs de la liberté
aux manifestants je le redis nous vous
avons entendus et il faut partir aux
travailleurs de l'industrie automobile
chauffeurs routiers tous ceux touchés
par le blocage du pont ambassador je le
redis nous prendrons toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour assurer la réouverture
de la frontière et aux habitants de ta
voix à cg je leur dis nous allons
veiller à ce que vous puissiez reprendre
une vie normale dès que possible
la décision de doug ford intervient
après que washington a mis la pression
sur le gouvernement canadien pour que
les axes routiers soient libérés
le pont ambassador actuellement bloqués
relier ottawa détroit et représentent un
large axe commercial entre les deux pays
25% des marchandises exportées entre le
canada et les états-unis transitent par
ce passage vendredi après midi un
tribunal canadien a ordonné la levée du
blocus du pont ambassador vous mon
canadien menace quant à lui d'employer
la manière forte pour déloger des
manifestants
tout est sur la table parce que cette
activité illégale doit cesser et elle
cessera bien sûr je ne peux pas en dire
plus maintenant sur le moment exact où
la manière dont cela se termine car
malheureusement nous sommes préoccupés
par la violence et nous prenons toutes
les précautions pour assurer la sécurité
des personnes mais la façon la plus sûre
de mettre fin à cette situation et que
chacun retourne dans sa communauté
maintenant
après deux semaines de mouvement
l'avenir du convoi de la liberté
canadien est en suspens la pression mise
sur les manifestants par le gouvernement
pourrait faire évoluer la situation dans
les prochains jours